salut! aujourd'hui on est jeudi
et le jeudi je parle de ce que je veux .et comme je parle de ce que je veux
et je me dis tiens je vais parler de moi, pas vraiment de moi de moi, évidement ça n'intéresse personne.
Ou pas grand monde en tout cas
Mais  d'un projet qui n'a rien à voir avec le spectacle en tout cas pas directement
et que j'ai lancé cette année au mois de mars avec plusieur personnes.
c'est un magazine
ladies and gentleman
laissez moi vous présenter
HUMOUR MAGAZINE
humour magazine c'est un petit "fanzine" sans pretention sur le millieu de l'humour
qui est édité a 30.000 exemplaire
et qu'on distribue gratuitement à l'entrée des spectacles dans Paris en fait
Les spectateur font la queue à des spectacles, et nous on arrive avec des équipes et on fait "tiens voila humour magazine prend le c'est sympa"
y'a plein de monde sur le projet,des gens qui écrivent ,des gens dans la logistique, des gens qui distribuent .
le projet c'était un magazine qui parlent des choses drôle
c'est pas forcément accès sur l'actualité brulante du milieu humoristique.
même si ça en parle quand même .
je vous fait visiter un petit peu
le dessin du thème du mois
parce que chaque mois il y a un thème sur le magazine
là, le thème du mois de mars était le printemps évidement. donc avec les couleurs un peu pastels.
et puis avec le fabuleux dessins de Jean-Sébastien Masset .
l’édito qui a était fait par Celine Holynski,qui est notre rédactrice en chef .La vous avez le sommaire.
ça c'est une interview de Laurent Gerra, une interviews pour le magazine  de Laurent Gerra ,c'est super cool
La ça parle d'un livre et d'un film.d'un livre drôle et d'un film drôle.
ils ne sont pas forcément hyper connus, enfin y'a des gens qui connaissent ,des gens qui connaissent pas .
c'est pas des choses qui viennent juste de sortir et c'est ça qui est intéressant
de revenir sur des choses qu'on veut vous faire découvrir
c'est le billet d'humour de Bonaf
tout les mois y'a quelqu'un qui écrit un billet d'humour
quelqu'un de différent
ça c'est un focus sur un one man show,c'est celui de vérino.
dans le bon plan on retrouve toutes les adresses,pour aller voir les spectacle dont on parle sur paris.
un autre interview ,alors y'a l'interview in et off
alors in c'est l'interview de quelqu’un qui est sur scène et off de quelqu’un qui n'est pas sur scène .
et Guillaume Sentou en général il est sur scène
mais il a fait pour la première fois une mise en scène
et ça c'est un interview sur lui mais en tant que metteur en scène.
hyper interessant
ça c'est une double page sur le rire sous toute ses formes
et surtout les origines du rire
et celui ci c'est un vrai article de fond sur l'origine du clown et des clowns.c'est intéressant et très sympa à lire
Sur le net, la on parle de Norman parce que y a un vrai lien en plus entre ces vidéos et ce qu'il fait maintenant sur scène
le but du jeu du dessin culte et de retrouver de quel film s'inspire cette image
et quel expression du film est caché dans l'image
celle du mois prochain et très drôle d'ailleurs
drôle de geek.pourquoi les geek rit
qu'est ce qui fait rire les geeks ?
un focus sur une comédie
c'est Erwan berener qui est aller voir une comédie et qu'il fait un compte rendue.
en plus son billet est très très drôle
Dans les drôles d'expressions, vous apprenez pourquoi on se dit "merde" avant d'aller jouer sur scène.
c'est moi qui ai écrit ça
Et voici vos anecdotes, tous les mois
on vous demande sur la page facebook de nous envoyer des anecdotes sur un thème bien précis
après on les remets en forme et on les publie
et ceux qui sont publiés reçoivent directement le magazine chez eux
il y a une personnes sur les 3 personnes qui reçoit 1 an d'abonnement à humour magazine
Ce mois-ci c'était olivier.
Je vous ai fait visiter les 32 pages .y'a un site internet,y'a un Facebook,y'a un twitter humour magazine.com
on est en train de faire le bouclage du prochain numéro parce que.
la sur les 30.000 il nous en reste 400 a distribuer et ils vont être distribués la ce week-end.
a l'entrée de certains théâtres dans Paris
et le prochain numéro sort le 1er avril le numéro 2.
qui sera tout bleu et le thème c'est le poisson d'avril,c'est les farces
c'est les farces on fais des farces.c'est vraiment un truc qui me tiens a cœur encore une fois,
c'est juste un simple fanzine.mais y'a un vrai contenu,y'a une vraie rédaction.un vraie travail qui aie fais dessus
ça nous prend beaucoup de temps et c'est un gratuit et c'est quelque chose qu'on donne
donc vous voyais l'idée c'est vraiment de faire découvrir tout ca, tout ce qui nous plais dans l'humour.je pense que le premier numéro,comme la il va être épuisé
on va le mettre en ligne sur le site internet
en format pdp comme ca vous pourraiez le lire aussi d'ici quelques jours
il devrait être en ligne directement sur le site et consultable .si vous êtes pas sur paris et que vous voulez être sur de le recevoir il y a aussi
la possibilité tout simplement de vous abonner au magazine, l'abonnement comprend les frais paypal.les frais postaux.
d'envoi postaux.et la tva.et hé.bon ba voila je sais pas du tout comment vous allez recevoir cette vidéo.
je voulez vous parler d'un truc qui me tiens vraiment a cœur et qu'on était dessus depuis le mois de septembre.
et puis la on est a fond depuis le mois de février puisque le premier numéro est sorti en mars.j'avais vraiment envie de le partager avec vous.
j'espere que ca vous aura interessé
et en tout cas que ça vous aura montrez une des autres nombreuses choses que je m'amuse a faire et qui me font vivre des journée de 72h
Hier dans la vidéos d'hier je vous aie parlé de lancer des sous titres .en fait sur les vidéos d'une manière collaboratif et participative.
Pour que même les personnes qui sont malentendantes puissent aussi comprendre les vidéos si ça vous motive de faire ce projet
Dites le moi dans les commentaires
et je vous expliquerais comment faire meme si vous en faite qu'une partie .meme si vous en faite la moitié d'une ca ouvrent les vidéos a plein de personnes
qui pouvait pas y avoir accès avant si vous voulez  me faire plaisir vous pouvez vous abonner à la chaine .puis ça participe a promouvoir la chaine.
a la faire connaitre encore un peu plus .comme quand vous partagez des vidéos.
la par exemple si vous partagez cette vidéos ba ca va faire encore plus connaître humour magazine.
et la chaine c'est cool
et puis moi je vous donne rendez vous demain a 17h
pour une mentalisation ce coup ci.
dans le prochain mental vlog ciao
...outro...